La up on to the wing D'Angelo got a piece of it
Parker Kelly flipped it across sh with a Chance
save Anderson rebound comes to Kelly Z fire
scores through from the point and a giveaway
here creates the first chance and a real good
save off the backat by Anderson but then they
get Puck recovered up top it's D'Angelo AO with it
spreading it out in front B works his way through
he's SC welcome to Carolina Michael bunny this was
a go scor's goal because it required patience with
the outstretched legs and stick that misses the
net pesi keeps it in his Drive deflected over the
top of the net Oh Carolina is swarming right now
across for ter he scores Carolina Shay had jumped
in from the Blue Line nearly scored and stayed
on the might be the key to that de voice of the
great Scotty mccre Martin up setting up stall
up Freddy SC stall in the trenches Martin puts
it in a place that thrown back by n orlock shot
is blocked race for it Joseph going after it he's
got Kelly going to the m Joseph Waits Kelly in
front shot scores uses his speed to his advantage
to block the shot and he's Off to the Races and
now it becomes a foot race with olar but then he
waits Waits finds the seam handing it off for
martinook off the boards taken away by Brady
kachu now carried up it's dless SC can he tell us
about the great competitive spirit this kid has
and he'll just take off here with great speed
and he gets all of this drips it right The Far
Side on Fredick Anderson good kick pocket there
from Martin on sta we get it to stall the fost
this line creating a chance and she scores top
of the circle tracking back with a purpose of all
purposes is Marner tries to find stall I think it
hits Escape retrieval from fost into the Auto Zone
Jarvis with it 7 seconds left in this PK slav
with it he scores shorthanded Jacob slaven has
changed his curve this year he's put a little bit
more curve out on the line with Noah Gregor and
David C TJ bro lost an edge Jake Evans away Evans
has a break EV in scores here he takes advantage
of the opportunity broy just gets himself all
tied good effort by Gregor to try to close the
gap and even get maybe a little slash in maybe
an odd man Rush here for monal Kirby dos got it
slowski in front scores and Alex new hook has his
first goal slowski does here though he makes the
play behind his own goal line and gets on his
horse and gets up in the play Doc doesn't have
grinding speed but look at sloski that's takes
toar for a split second pass Harvey Bernard at
Center Quick Pass good one by mck over the line
here comes Gregor scores no Gregor Greer jumps
up the linesman gives a point that it's okay A
little hesitation to the inside a delay to the
outside first good look on this third power
play now martyr in front Matthews scor hits
number 300 right on the door step is Matthews
a reach back but look at where he shoots that
puck from from his back foot Matthews Marner down
low it bounces to davaris Knocked away and nander
reloads gets it back 40 goal season last year
if You' watched William neander the one thing
he's really been able to do is Power Shot Through
from the longer range what goes to Suzuki watched
by Camp back to mat seen pass C field scores so
instead of forcing it right away watch this little
adjustment bro comes up out now you move your
feet and then you get a lucky break Sosi came
across to take it away back to dock new hook
trying to make himself available instead it's
Jacky scores great athle athleticism by samsonov
but it's doc again who buys a little time with
a rotation there's the high tip by new hook you
have both left now on turnover here's pulling it
in backand scores TI you remember the game's
first goal it was Brody who lost his balance
here's a similar play whiffed on the puck and then
fell down and this is a tight play earlier in the
week net empty leaps need one to get within
one and tarus Matthew scores nothing's really
happening you get an offensive zone face off a
bold decision and sometimes the simplest play
is the best one and here's one just rotate
from down low up to high Tavaris goes down
and you can see Al bumped along the boards
trying to pin it there Marner had it Loose
Monahan spins KN Lander intercepts across
and with down one score seen so many times
from Battle win the puck in the corner and
get it to the front of the Nets first time
not able to get control but Matthews stays
with it though dropping it back off now with
a shot by coming he scores his first National
Hockey League goal little pitch and catch with
Ryan Donado he takes a shot not from a great
angle but look at the presence by Hall and
ability as far as a workload and just be really
selective when you really kind of go soal all
out there's Carlo on the feet from pker SC
Frei and a great look by our crew no chance
her and you talk about some of the veterans
that help you out stay a from L skating left
head up shooting right right in between
the left arm battle for the puck it
ahead scor the puck laying
there it's fre somebody's
got to get it and Maran justs hiset he [Applause]
CH Dylan du back to Noah Hanahan Hanahan takes a
look here's RKA shoots never got it there rebound
SC on the power play B [__] makes it one up
the Calgary their them is to get lots of Pucks
in that with traffic and you see Michael Batman
going to the front rid's going to get the puck
and just throw it in front it goes off the 33
points gets the puck to Samberg and here comes
Connor over the line with a shot scores K
Conor sneaks one through they exit their
Zone nicely here's that nice pass right through
the middle and watch how Conor just changes the
angle Walker doer back to sidorov here's weager
wrer scores weager off the draw puts it home and
the Flame's up two one that's how you just
sort of sip bucks through keep the pressure
on Dello looking for a deflection in front ey
Apollo couldn't get a stick to it half to the
puck finds Lowry glovs it down deelo long shot
scores I'll follow in front with a tip beautiful
redirect deelo with a real nice Flames are on
and here goes lenol with back shorthanded LOL
takes a look try to hit Hanan who join the rush
now he plays it back Anderson scores sers he's
going to get up in the pl watch this pass from L
looks a little bit dangerous but he's sof it in
there arrom over to Han to the point not
out Mory kept it in here's shley scores
doesn't look as though Marksman leaves
much room whatsoever markom knows at
Connor is to his right Jonathan huo
puts the puck behind the net to l
scores on japon and without ever waiting he
recognizes that he has lolm going to the front
of the neck he'll feed it ahead and they get
it pass Mor Out Racing after it hoo and they
up it out here's hoo off the post maon follows
up score watch this play right there just cats
it P Mory now it's bian and huor surprisingly
kuo hits the PO with M comes in getting that
puck over to Conor Garland he realizes he
has some space hands it off to peton back
to Garland and what a beautiful goal for Conor
Garland and a lot of talk about him talking to
other organizations and having that permission
Elliot Freeman with a great as Bard now racing
to the put D Jai there as well JT Miller pouncing
on it finds B through the shot and he scores R
Ned wanting to get back to a great start and this
is how you do it you come out excellent for check
by the Canucks here DJI this line combination has
been together all training camp for the Vancouver
Canucks spend some time in the gym together
here's heroni coming in with a wrist rebound
Jack Campell made the initial save with the
connect [Applause] score and it finds its way
in Campbell trying to deny it a second time
it's the patient play of B great backhand Fe
gives it over to Pon moving into kzo Pon has
it again from the corner Elias Pon and that pu
trickles into the net Brock bisser but let's take
another look at this goal and there it is there
and you can see Jack Campell that slow motion
he's already reading D was looking to cover up
that puck another opportunity blue Shard back
to McDavid McDavid down low one timer tricyle
shoots and scores as soon as that penalty was
taken and they didn't like it too much of some
shaking heads get your feet moving backtrack and
lesson learn as the power play goes to work you
give them chances give them looks and eventually
over to JT Miller back to pon pon finds Quinn
Hughes Hughes more of a shot mentality from him in
the preseason here's a shot and this time it's Pon
good movement around here for Quinn Hughes goes
down to the half wall typically where Pon would
be he feels in the position where Hughes usually
is no question he's stopping here's Hughes with a
shot towards the net and Brock besser has four
tonight in the kak season opener in the right
spot at the right time you want to score goals
in this league it's never a bad idea to get to
the net you can see broberg has him right at the
top of the crease right through here's JT Miller
the rer and it's in the [Applause] minut to the
pon goal use the shot through the screen very
willing to get shots through and you can see de
har trying to get into his shooting Lane here's
Heros now to Myers quickly up the wall and on the
attack again is Sam lafy coming in with speed up
pass over to Joshua esar that he denies and on the
ensuing play it's just a puck battle one and give
lafy some credit here the Speedy McLoud can't
track him down he'll leave it at the line as he
entered for drewan saes with Roy behind for for
rany kicked it to his stick chipped to the front
McKinnon scores he was the one that poked it over
to Ranon who plays it beautifully over there to
McKinnon who goes Kings work on this penalty kill
that was a problem for them last year ran bups it
out McKinnon had to move in a hurry behind the
back right to the car step shoot scores with the
ability to shoot the puck from the point but ranin
was the player that entered the Zone quick little
backhand pass and kale Mari thought was going to
fire it right away he does m ranted and all alone
in the mle and he did ped it off for Taves and the
shot was deflected by fiala ranted and scores got
basically flat on the goal line on a reverse VH
and there's loads of Jack Johnson has to hurry up
to get to that for grun wiping out with Manson so
was Johnson they [Applause] score just recognizes
right after the hit he can beat him and stepped
up the blue line bouncing Puck y knocked it down
and they score by any stretch of imagination but
you're right face off at Cent r a high flip it a
perfect one with a little bit of spin on it right
there by Anderson taken down here's ma across the
ice for Jack Johnson with a r shot scores M
ran in and the shot from the point but that's
established Colorado is how much can the use gor
with an empty net here for La a chance for Miles
wood to put it away but this right here what a
dive what a I mean col's had a great game guys